all right Adib how you doing adeeb uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally uh I grew up in Atlanta
Georgia that's my hometown
and tell me about your family you had
Mom and Dad uh yes my mom I live with my
mom and my dad and I'm an only child so
I didn't really have any other children
for the parental energy to manifest in
so I get some a lot of the over
protection or a lot of uh
um over focusing you know I wish I had a
more intricate family dynamic
how far are you in school
I went to my school was spotty I
attended third and fifth and sixth grade
ninth eventually I got my GED in 2010.
what was your school experience like
um
I was heavily bullied I was uh well
teased and and taunted basically uh
children can be like piranhas basically
a lot of people say they can be innocent
but they can be like piranhas They
bucked at me or when they knew I
couldn't fit in a social Paradigm they
threw insults at me and I really
couldn't converse with them and that's
kind of how depersonalization and this
disassociation started basically the
lack of and the bullying was mostly
because you were autistic yeah I
couldn't you know get down with the get
down I wasn't on any social wavelength
whatsoever I was very quiet and then
whoa look at this choir person like
maybe we should uh pick on them or you
know pick pieces and the other times I
was
trying to be bravado trying to distill
an image that I didn't know that that I
shouldn't be producing rather so they
would try to g-check me and
I was doing too much as they say in the
hood they said you do too much right so
either I did nothing or I did too much
and I still got it at either it what is
autism can you describe oh yes autism is
the uh over connection of neurons in the
human brain so let's say a regular
person might have 50 or 75 percent
interconnectivity autistic people have
like 80 or 93 like but I'm not a
neuroscientist but something like that
like neurons connect to things that uh
they shouldn't connect to uh basically
and so that so that'll lead you into
what kind of behavior or what what are
the characteristics characteristics of
somebody who's autistic uh what are the
characteristics of people who are
artistic um
um there are like there are constants
that uh autistic people have
specifically young autistic children
um always in awe always
anxious uh always
um
extremely focused yet high at the same
time as
a weak feeling and we would feel this as
a child I would feel different
combinations of the five of sometimes
all of them at the same time and it
becomes very uh tiresome basically and
that those constants are dependent upon
input for example if a different routine
is changed or a different social
situation or maybe the ceiling is high
instead of being lower we're in a BJs
instead of
a a regular Kroger I don't know just
anything any change on the inputs makes
these constants more painful for
autistic children basically so you you
had difficulty socially
were there other areas of your life that
were difficult
uh other areas in my life that were
difficult
um
I would say the symptoms the symptoms
were difficult in terms of having autism
like what symptoms would you
um the symptoms of of autism
or over caring slash over emotional so I
remember if I would hear something sad
that would happen politically I would
cry and let's say I was watching a TV
show with my mom Everybody Loves Raymond
TBS 2007 and I would just scream and
jump with laughter Just For Joy pretty
much too much using too much emotion and
the the second symptom these these two
are subtle the second symptom would be
over proxying so for example I was
getting whoopings or something bad
happened in my life and I would plug in
so to speak from a virtual world so part
of the sadness in my life whether it was
the I think the Fat Albert movie or
Clifford the Big Red Dog I would somehow
draw upon that in terms of my sadness
and I think that might be uh autism
basically another thing another autism
artistic thing that would be on this
step two would be uh memorization I
remember I memorized like an entire uh
episode of uh this kids TV show
basically I think it was Cyberchase or
something so those are the two light
aspects now uh the heavier aspects
um
I remember
I couldn't sleep alone
um I always thought that there was a
demon in the closet and it's crazy I
tried to suffocate myself
so either I guess the demon wouldn't
basically I would um completely cover
cover my face with the cupboards and uh
I had a hard time in terms of peeing in
the bed that didn't stop until I was 13
years of age
and I would try to sleep with my parents
so I try to go with my mom and um uh
I would be she was watching Who Wants To
Be A Millionaire and I was afraid when
the light turned green from yellow so I
was very very over sensitive in that
manner lots of anxiety it sounds like
yeah lots of anxiety
um
uh artistic I remember in elementary
school I was somewhat turned off by my
own body heat and at times I got dizzy
that's just a a little bit of the of the
symptoms of of autism School in general
was just difficult your social life and
all that must have been yeah
non-existent very very painful yeah
how old are you now I'll be 28 in
January so as you've aged has it has it
mellowed or changed
um has it changed
I would say
um
I would say time is uh is hard on
autistic people because
uh
there's something called autistic
regression where basically you reach a
point and then
you start to fade backwards kind of so
um
I got my GED I did good at um
at a technical college
but then all of a sudden I was majoring
in I.T I reached the level
where I saw that I didn't have any
problem solving skills
because
I didn't have enough schooling I had
pretty much the problem solving skills
of a sixth grader because everything bad
happened in high school we chased away
the teacher or for math two I was so
bullied that I couldn't
study basically I couldn't get the
information because they were constantly
bullying me so
um it wasn't just that of different
addictions that stopped me from being
able to to study I.T or I was never
interested in it those two are valid but
the third one is that
it's it's crazy I graduated 3.43 GPA in
it
and I have the problem solving skills of
a freaking sixth grader like how do you
explain that that's that's educational
that's
that's pretty tough
when you when you mention addictions
what kind of addictions do you have
um
when uh what type of uh
addictions basically
um
uh the addictions that I had well it
started out
um
I think I can start out with my uh my
mom she was kind of
overprotective right she would um
whether it was washing my face or what
food I ate or the my the people in my
social life that She chased away your
mom was very overprotective yeah very
overprotective she's still to this day
she still doesn't trust me to cross the
street I'll be 28 in January right and
if I say I want to live alone she'll say
why it won't work or all of those things
pretty much suffocating feeling like
obsessed with me basically I heard uh uh
Jordan Peterson use the adage in old
infant which kind of stung when I heard
him like damn you know so that's very
overprotective there and and back to
your addictions what what kind of
addictions do you do you have
um I think it's it was constantly being
bullied by the kids at school I would
feel like prey or property or just just
real horrible and these intense emotions
of autism right this I think there's
something wrong with our bioelectric
feedback or just our bioelectrical
systems we feel so much energy
um between that Mom and a social life I
had in a bad social life with the kids
at school I developed uh pre-fetishes as
a kid what is that what is a prefetish
um okay for instance I I tied myself up
when I was young because uh one thing
about autism sometimes my chest I feel
this negative pressure so and this is
many years later I would like tighten
the shirt up so I won't feel the the
trauma uh with my chest some type of
weird feeling basically but then it was
more severe I was tying myself up I
gagged myself a couple times and uh
I love my mom's bra I would always
kidnap the bra it was nothing else but
uh well there were some tight leather
pants near the end but I I would just
feel this weird addictive uh energy like
it was a drug or something and the more
I did it you know the more it uh
it kind of took over basically so and um
I always dreamed
of that I was in a hole in a tight space
with my crush basically like that was a
recurring dream and as a young boy I
always dreamed that I wanted to get
married which is weird because usually
that's supposed to be a girl's domain
but always dreamed about about getting
married down the aisle
with between that and the trapped in the
hole with my crush that that's just
freaking weird but that's those were my
uh uh Proto fetishes my pre-fetishes
basically
I remember I walked out of the shower
with only my chest cupboard but not
my lower regions so that won't happen
one time basically so
yeah
and you've you've had romantic
relationships or no
um
romantic relationships my first romantic
relationship was uh a Dom May a
dominatrix who was trying to double as
my life coach and uh
I'm not sure I want to I guess
discuss that um
but uh
so yeah I talked about I talked about
what would that talk about yeah about my
prefetishes and there were two things
that uh
that uh led me to a point two huge
events one of them is what I call uh
what was it Day Zero basically and that
was a huge panic attack I had uh
I had
my mom had to do the heinlich maneuver
on me because I was so stressed out like
with autistic children panic attacks are
very common basically so she had to give
me the Heimlich maneuver and it was as
if I saw the faces of 50 gods and 50
demons uh I experienced trauma at night
I woke up uh and um I felt like I was
gonna die I was playing my an old 2000
video game controller in in 2006 and I
felt like I was gonna die that that pan
attack was horrible there was another
panic attack that happened to me it was
um it was in Value Village and you know
how blind people have a glazed eye and I
looked into his eye and all of a sudden
it's as if the Edgar Allan pole is the
exact story that happened to me as
I saw stars and I felt extremely weak
and dehydrated and I collapsed to the
floor basically so panic attacks I think
with my compromise uh
uh nervous system by Electric System
whatever
um is what prepared me for falling for
porn of so much and what really led to
my descent in porn was I watched the
horror movie called uh jigsaw so I was
an autistic 13 or 14 year old so parents
always have to be careful of what their
children are watching because and to
this day I still I look on the movie of
Value Village and it's as if okay that
was the movie that you know took my soul
or something like that right it
basically the the panoramic camera
angles of the screens and people
yoked or or the Contraptions or
restrained in somehow that pretty much
just took that control that's what
turned it from pre-fetish into uh fetish
fetish basically it was uh that movie
would you consider yourself an addict a
porn addict
you know I wanted to title this uh
autism mishandled but yeah I would call
it porn addict now that you brought it
so uh real critique so clear uh
basically and um when I went into uh uh
uh started watching some fetish porn
sites
oh that's when my sex drive had a huge
increase I was
pleasuring myself eight hours at night
um
it's as if
the spirit of like
70 or like the spirit of 20 female porn
stars
um let's say uh diamond or the the maybe
eight as well as eight male porn stars
let's say uh Marcus had literally the
density of all those porn stars was
over my entire body right just just the
combination of of raw sex I was eight
hours nine hours and I would see people
being tied up or or
restrained and I would feel I wanted
women to do that uh to me basically I
want women to rather choke me or do all
these graphic things I'm not going to
discuss or rope or something and uh the
um
it became
my dream to be
a submissive so we won't use the uh the
the the the other s word it was it was a
dream of mine and it turned into a drug
like to avoid
um
all the feelings of autism and the the
negative uh
the feedback that how did how did porn
affect your autism or vice versa
um
how did porn affect uh
my autism
um
I I was thinking of something else I was
thinking of
something else but um
um
something called uh
um
it was no longer local right it was done
uh locality basically so let's say
you're watching someone else pleasure
themselves well for an autistic child
you almost become the person like I
would say non-locality I didn't mention
it it's a it's like an inverted image of
of the person basically so uh
you know
so they feel something you feel
something is like a VR it's like a
haptic feedback basically you know it's
it's real crazy
and you've had relationships with women
I didn't have any relationships until my
first uh
uh the domain in 2014 basically
so I would use porn as a drug if I
couldn't
um
just paying for my autism or the
overprotective mom or
um you know
my Mom said she could she didn't even
trust me to get a fast food job she kept
saying that the people were bullying me
like they did in high school so and then
there's people in high school
um
well that was later uh so porn was kind
of like something you sniff or something
you inject and you just get this huge
you know escape from your problems but
like all drugs
like all drugs um
uh it only adds to your problems and you
still have your existing problems
and so your personal relationship
Incorporated some of these fetishes
um we never really got there that that
much it was mostly talk and the whole uh
I was uh
that's mostly talk I forgot the correct
word for it but yeah basically
looking back here
at your life you're only 28 but what
would what do you wish you had done
differently anything you regret
uh and anything that I've done I wish
that I didn't fall for I guess sex or
porn so much or
been a hassle to my mom or working on my
worked on myself more I just let myself
fade after 2014.
take responsibility because yeah I had a
lot of I had a lot of problems that I
mentioned but I didn't I wasn't strong
enough there was this saying by a
motivational speaker that I just
realized that I just knew existed his
name is Jim Rohn he said don't uh hope
don't hope for life to be easier hope to
be better
so I hope I wish I was better I want to
be better
and you wanted to share your story
yeah what motivated you to
um to talk about autism
I wanted to help young autistic kids out
there that are
uh might have a similar story as mine
um
the so they won't fall into the gaps
that I've fallen into they won't fall
into the holes that I've fallen into and
a big one is what I would call
uh
digital molestation you know
which is what the the a digital
molestation
um so for example you can compare
uh let's do a brief comparison of
digital versus real molestation let's
say someone reacts a kid unfortunately
is reacting to a real molestation uh
unfortunately and I'm only saying this
statistically so I don't want every
everyone to say whoa it's some sort of
natural normalness unfortunately that
people have raped each other and at some
point the victim the adults or the kid
um places all the blame the kid places
all the blame onto the attacker at some
point with
uh porn sure there's the internet of
companies oh why is uh why aren't they
censoring the 100 gigabit uh of Kink
that's flowing that the child might be
watching and their parents home yeah
there's the internet companies the
actors
um there's all that but fundamentally
there's just the laptop and it's just
the child that's looking at the laptop
so it's hard to put the blame on someone
else because well it's him that's doing
it largely you know in many cases the
child finds it basically so uh the
characteristics of molotation of
molestation is physical mental
or spiritual and
um that's basically what virtual uh
molestation is I I feel sort of I don't
want to say virtual rape but a virtual
molestation because everything starts in
in the brain right you have powerful
rocket ships and Intel processors and I
believe there's one thing religious that
was attributed that I think it was Jesus
that if you look into the eyes
with uh lust it's as if you've committed
adultery so everything really starts in
the mind and we're seeing everything
virtual so that's what I say about uh
virtual molestation
what advice would you give to somebody
who's
who has a child who's Autistic or
somebody who's autistic like yourself
um what have you learned
now this is an example that uh of why I
would say virtual model station is real
because it's something that the parents
would never imagine happening basically
and even if
they somewhat know or imagine they'll be
like you know like that that's not
really happening or you know not like
turning a blind eye a blind eye to it
but basically the parents perspective is
oh my child that that would never happen
with my child my child would never fall
into that type of uh
gutter or hole or that with real
molestation it's it it's maybe a close
family member or a friend but with the
virtual it's you would never get into
that or that's an outlet so just realize
that porn is always there even more than
a pervy friend or an uncle
what do you hope to do from here on we
would like to be in five years
well I hope to be in for um
I will hope to be in five years
um my last relationship was
I had three relationships really uh only
one of them was the was was the domain
so um
I would like to be in a relationship I
think I realized I have my own apartment
I need to get a car
uh I need to get a job up and continue
my entrepreneurship efforts I can't wait
till I'm mentally uh available because
people always talk about trauma bonding
so wait till I'm mentally sound or
stable that's going to take until the
heat death of the universe to happen so
I I need to work on the uh
the mechanic the physicals kind of as
well as the financial
aspect and hopefully a little mental but
uh yeah
all right well thank you so much for
sharing your story and I wish you lots
of luck from here on out no thank you
thank you very much